alors ce pavillon orange que
représentent-ils et bien tout simplement
que la ville dispose d'une réserve
communale de sécurité civile
vous êtes élu dans cette ville de
neauphle à quoi sert cette réserve
quelles sont ses missions alors la
réserve comme son nom l'indiqué est un
réservoir de jean ii qui sont bénévoles
et qui sont sous contrat avec la mairie
et qui vont servir en fait leurs
concitoyens au sein de la commune et en
cas de crise d'événements majeurs vont
les aider à passer le cap c'est à dire
si on prend des exemples quand on se
rappelle des tempêtes un peu forte que
nous avons eu donc aider son concitoyen
c'est le rôle du réserviste il n'est pas
là pour faire le travail de la
gendarmerie ou des secours des pompiers
et autres mais il est là comme une
assistance à la population un apport
logistique qui permet de prévenir et de
guérir c'est à dire de aussi lorsque le
problème et est survenue de revenir à la
normale il ya donc ce pavillon orange
qui flotte au-dessus de la municipalité
au dessus de l'hôtel de ville la
population est consciente de ça pour
préserver les interroge encore va dire
oui on veut dire non elle sera de plus
en plus consciente de par le fait que
nous mettons des panneaux à l'entrée de
la ville qui vont signaler cet
événement ce label qui est comme vous
l'avez souligné concerne aujourd'hui une
trentaine de villes qui sont vus
attribuer ce label 'par le haut' comité
français de défense et de sécurité
civile mais bon on espère de faire
décroître et multiplier le nombre de
communes dans les yvelines notamment
d'accords vos voisins vont s'y
intéresser vont prendre quelques
renseignements auprès de la municipalité
c'est vrai que le un des enjeux je crois
personnellement c'est que ce cette
réserve et par là-même aussi la génèse
c'est le plan communal de sauvegarde qui
est quand même un point important de que
toute commune devrait se doter
devraient aussi être rétabli dans
l'ensemble des communes de coeur divine
puisque nous sommes au sein d'une
communauté de communes est ici toutes
les communes de cette communauté de
communes avait à la fois le la réserve
et le label ça serait l'idéal est-ce
qu'ils avaient une obligation à mettre
en place cette réserve justement
pourquoi la municipalité a fait le choix
de la développer alors aucune obligation
il faut comprendre que suite aux
événements de 2001 septembre 2001 un
certain nombre de choses ont bougé en
france un petit peu avec retard et en
2004 la loi de modernisation de sécurité
civile a amené à donner des outils aux
maires qui sont le plan communal de
sauvegarde et la réserve communale de
sécurité civile et donc il n'y a pas
d'obligation mais il est quand même
fortement conseillé que et avec l'aide
de la préfecture qui doit puis un peu
ceux du département qui doit appuyer
cela de mener ce genre
d'exercice qui est le plan communal de
sauvegarde
et pour rendre ce plan communal de
sauvegarde vivant la réserve est un
outil un outil au service de la
population aux services du maire puisque
nous sommes quand même piloté par le
maire donc ce sont des bénévoles qui
interviennent
comment vous les choisissez ses
bénévoles et puis quels sont les types
d'interventions concrètes sur lesquelles
peuvent intervenir et sont peut-être
déjà intervenu d'ailleurs voilà passé
alors nous sommes nous sommes tous
bénévoles moi-même y compris
déjà en tant que conseiller municipal et
conseiller défense qui est un autre
sujet que l'on pourra par une prochaine
fois puisque dans toutes les communes de
france il ya un conseiller défense donc
36000 communes trente six mille
conseiller défense est donc un
conseiller défense qu'est ce qu'il faut
qu'ils forment que fait-il eh bien s'ils
ne créent pas un plan communal de
sauvegarde et s'ils ne créent pas
derrière une réserve je pense que c'est
un aussi un moyen aussi de se faire
quelques images d'ailleurs de vos
collègues de cette réserve voilà la
commune qui peuvent intervenir
absolument rien leur mission alors leur
mission bien eux sont des revenus par
l'assisté sauvegarder alors ils sont
intervenus par exemple on s'était en je
crois en
2011 c'était ou 2010 déjà le temps passe
nous sommes d'intervenir au côté de la
gendarmerie pour battre la campagne et
faire la recherche d'une personne qui
s'était qui évaporé qui avait été enlevé
en fait une personne de
neauphle-le-château et on a battu les à
la forêt environnante avec la
gendarmerie et nous étions à l'époque 11
réservistes 11 réservistes qui ont qui
sont mis à disposition de la gendarmerie
qui ont rajouté du volume de la
gendarmerie a toujours du mal à trouver
elle-même des réservistes et donc on a
battu la campagne et cette personne a
été retrouvée aux mureaux mais c'était
un peu plus loin et donc il ya vu un
enlèvement et donc ces drames ont créé
un exemple concret qui s'est produit par
le passé cette réserve est intervenue
mais ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
peut-être de souligner pour conclure le
fait que ça crée du lien aussi au sein
de la colonne un lien entre générations
aussi par exemple le lien entre
générations nous intervenons en été et
en hiver par exemple en été lorsqu'il ya
des fortes chaleurs et en hiver
lorsqu'il ya des grands froids et voir
de la neige une démission ces deux
d'aider les personnes fragilisées de la
commune de se porter au devant d'elle
les aider à faire leurs courses les
aider vous les visités tout simplement
et comprendre que faire un peu de
communication et faire en sorte qu'elles
sont moins seul voilà un exemple concret
et qui est récurrent et si on souhaite
rejoindre ses réservistes alors et des
tests à passer non il n'ya pas deux il
faut être apte effectivement parce que
d'abord il faut être motivé le but c'est
de donner de son temps parce que quand
j'appelle la réserve pour un exercice
dans les quinze minutes qui suivent la
réserve est à pied d'oeuvre et ça arrive
souvent et il y en aura un exercice en
juin n'est pas donné hiller mais met
donc les gens sont doivent être motivées
doivent donc donner de leur temps ils
doivent aussi ces gens être en état
physique suffisant pour porter quelque
chose se déplacer et on voit pas les
secourir celles qui doivent se couvrir
donc voilà donc il faut et puis on fait
appel au bénévolat par affiches part par
le biais de notre site web et nous avons
recruté dernièrement quatre personnes
elles peuvent encore se manifester c'est
un
réservoir non limitatif et donc les
personnes sont sont répartis par cartier
puisque finalement on est dans une forme
d'îlotage puisque c'est quand même
important de connaître les gens de son
quartier et donc on a découpé nos flancs
cinq quartiers et donc il ya les
personnes sont réparties comme ça et
donc font des tournées de
2e
vis-à-vis des personnes fragilisées
notamment et puissant aussi parfois
alors ce ne sont pas des mercenaires ce
ne sont pas des comme on pourrait le
penser pour certains non on est là pour
vraiment nous mettra à disposition des
bénévoles pour vrai
j'ai enlevé l'égoïsme sortir de
l'égoïsme parce que on s'aperçoit qu'on
est d'une société de plus en plus
égoïste et ce sera le mot de conclusion
voilà en espérant qu'elle soit motivée
certaines bonnes volontés sur votre
commune merci à vous toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que nos fallait
donc l'une de ces trente communes en
france à avoir ce pavillon orange chez
est l'une des rares dans le département
des yvelines avoir ce potentiel de
réservistes à disposition